well let's speak to our people in
politics correspondent nick martin uh
we've had some words from the business
secretary in the last half hour or so at
nick trying to reassure people about the
security of the energy sector what can
you tell us yeah quasi quantum as we
know has been in meetings today
on saturday a sign perhaps that there is
a growing concern within government and
he issued some comments on his own
social media account in the last hour
which he he is trying to reassure it's
almost reads to be honest with you like
crisis what crisis quasi-carteng said
the security of the uk's gas supply is
not a cause for immediate concern he
says the gas system in the united
kingdom continues to operate he said it
continues to operate reliably and he
says he does not expect gas supply
emergencies this winter this is despite
those costs going up and up and up month
on month the prices the price of gas is
crucial here we do have the energy price
cap which is in place to try and pre
protect consumers at times where the
global price and the wholesale gas price
that's the price did companies buy and
pass on to the customer the cap does
exist and he hopes that that will serve
to protect consumers he said some energy
companies are facing problems that's
obviously come out of that conversation
today he says there are initiatives in
place to try and protect consumers the
winter fuel payment for elderly cold
weather payments uh warm house discount
he says as i've just said energy
companies are facing pressure he says
off gem that's the off the um energy
regulator has robust measures in place
to ensure that customers do not need to
worry he says we'll see